[Musique]
cette région vit depuis le génocide de
1915 un drame ethniques très important à
la faveur de l'année 2020 alors que
recep tayyip erdogan chercher des moyens
d'étendre son pouvoir
après avoir essayé en libye après avoir
menacé chypre encore une fois après
avoir foré dans les eaux territoriales
de chypre après avoir survolé la grece
avec des avions armés y compris les
territoires occupés et habitée après
avoir violé les eaux territoriales
grecques
après avoir massacré les kurdes que nous
avons abandonné
eh bien il s'est dit que c'était le
moment d'envoyer ses troupes azéries à
l'assaut de ce pauvre territoire de lac
sarthe et malheureusement cette guerre
de quelques semaines a été menée dans
des conditions particulièrement cruel
pire encore les turco azéri ont
commandité des djihadistes qui l'ont
payé pour aller massacrer des arméniens
les rêves délirants d'expansionnisme
turc de recep tayyip erdogan ont été
satisfaits puisque désormais il va
bénéficier d'un couloir turcophones qui
va aller de la mer noire jusqu'à la mer
caspienne en grignotant sur le
territoire même de la république
d'arménie
recep tayyip erdogan l'a dit il souhaite
que le drapeau de l'islam flotte sur la
terre d'arc sarthe et imanaliev a crié
victoire en disant qu'il avait chassé
les arméniens comme des chiens la france
doit sortir de sa neutralité
désormais plusieurs choses sont devant
nous la première c'est la reconnaissance
pour la protection de cette population
la deuxième c'est de faire en sorte que
dans le cessez le feu est bien on parle
aussi du territoire de la xsara et de la
préservation des vies humaines mais
aussi des vestiges historiques qui sont
les traces du royaume d'arménie parce
que ça appartient au patrimoine
de l'humanité